[Music]
oh you so you move your position for the
pool that's good
makes a difference
thank you
there's something to discharge i will do
a waffle check with you
see how my audio sounds and make sure my
lip is sinking
properly check check check one two three
one two three audio check one two one
two
okay i got you all right cool good to go
thank you bye
sure audio check one two one two audio
check one two three
four five six seven eight all right
thank you
[Laughter]
like
i want to make your fingers sick
appointment thank you
i love the sound of that shutter click
man
i bet she can hear it
together
sir
get like the best pictures you know have
you seen this picture
my credit card number
well we got to see the results first man
you see it for 50 if you wanted it's
200. 50
are you shooting up the stadium
runway oh my god
oh
foreign
foreign
i went to something on it years ago um
like i'm gonna be
um
is
[Music]
see
okay
foreign
um
um
guys
um
um
everybody
what's happening
thank you
thank you
all right
hello
yes sir do you have
uh your soul unit that's good
right yeah you gotta take a look at it
when he makes it
oh if i give him the kill
he said you're the one you can adjust
the power
to
he doesn't have any problems yeah but i
never have problems
with mine
then push the power on and then you go
down the list
like that question mark
going out to all of them
ah there are two levels
uh
thank you
their editors
[Music]
is
if
okay
[Music]
channel
um
right
lady
when
uh hello victor mike check one two three
four five six
thank you
okay
all right
let's do it
a few steps that way
[Music]
okay
hey
thank you
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
okay can you step like three steps that
way keep going
that's better
hey
so
i yeah
oh
okay
what's up
okay
so
is it okay now though
all right
so
two-minute warning for the press
briefing two-minute warning for the
press briefing
thank you
so
we have two minutes
hi everyone
tj has an alarm going on he's excited
about the briefing
okay just a couple of things for you all
at the top
the president and his entire
administration are continuing to engage
closely with leaders on capitol hill
about the need to act quickly on the
american rescue plan
so we can finish the job of getting two
thousand dollar checks out to americans
so we can get more vaccines in the arms
of americans
so we can get economic relief to
families facing eviction or food
insecurity
and so we can help reopen schools safely
we're encouraged that both speaker
pelosi and majority leader schumer are
in full agreement about the need to move
swiftly on the president's proposal
and the committee markups we'll see
throughout the week are evidence of
congress acting on that expeditiously
our expectation is that this week's
house markups will track closely with
what the president
has proposed but there will of course be
adjustments to strengthen the bill
and tweaks as a result of the
legislative process which he's quite
familiar with having served there for 36
years
which is exactly how the process is
supposed to work
we're also going to continue to make the
case directly to the american
people about the urgency of getting this
package across the finish line
including through national and local tv
and radio interviews engagement with
hundreds of mayors and county elected
officials
consultations with stakeholders across
the political spectrum
from label labor and rural leaders to
the faith community
here's a quick overview a number of
you've asked about this of the sense of
the scope of our efforts
over a dozen senior administration
officials have conducted over 100
national tv radio and podcast interviews
to discuss the american rescue plan
we've done over 30 local tv interviews
in states ranging from
nevada to louisiana to pennsylvania and
the last week alone our legislative
affairs team had done more than 300
calls with members and staff on the hill
including 40 calls with republicans
or bipartisan groups and you can expect
that the president will engage
throughout the course of this week with
a range of
stakeholders including business leaders
mayors and governors
and as we've discussed before
this message is resonating poll after
poll show a
bipartisan majority of the american
people in support
of the president's plan a couple of
other quick updates for all of you
many folks lately likely noticed if you
all watch the super bowl the president
the first lady yesterday appeared in a
psa that aired during the pregame show
thanking healthcare workers and
addressing
the importance of continuing to wear
masks and getting vaccinations
when it's your turn this is a good
example of how you can expect the white
house in the coming months
to reach out with critical public health
messaging as part of an education
campaign
meeting americans where they are on
their couches watching the super bowl
for yesterday
and communicating about the important
mitigation steps
people can take as many of you also know
last night during the super bowl
president biden called service members
to thank them for their courage
dedication and service to our nation
he first called troops with resolute
support mission in kabul
and then uh the uss nimitz he then
shared via
ship broadcast and message to the nearly
5 000 sailors and marines
who comprised the uss nimitz crew
um with that uh let's answer your
questions go ahead alex thanks jen i
have two
the first is on your favorite topic in
does the president have plans to watch
any of the trial this week and
does the white house prefer a speedy
impeachment trial or
would the president prefer a full airing
of the violence at the capitol and
role in inciting it through things like
live witnesses
well uh first the president himself
would tell you that we keep him pretty
busy
and he has a full schedule this week
which we will continue to keep you
abreast of um and as soon as we have
more details but
we've already announced his plans to go
visit the nih to go visit the department
of defense
as i noted he will be engaging with
business leaders mayors and governors
and of course continuing to make the
case and have conversations with
democrats and republicans directly about
his hopes and plans for the american
rescue plan moving forward
as quickly as possible so he i think
it's clear
from his schedule and from his intention
he will not spend
too much time watching the proceedings
of any time
over the course of this week he will
remain in closely in touch with speaker
pelosi leader schumer
a range of officials on the hill about
his plan and that's exactly
uh what they want him to do is to remain
focused on that
um and he will leave the uh pace and the
process and the mechanics of the
impeachment proceedings up to members of
congress
the president said there's no need for
trump to receive intelligence briefings
has trump requested any has he received
any and is that the official
decision or who is that decision left up
to
well the president said when asked that
he had there was no need for him to
receive them uh
and he referenced of course his erratic
behavior which i think many americans
would agree with him on
he was expressing his concern about
former president
trump receiving access to sensitive
intelligence
but he also has deep trust in his
intelligence own intelligence team
to make a determination about how to
provide intelligence information
if at any point the former president
requests a briefing so that's not
currently applicable but if he should
request a briefing uh he leaves at the
dem to make a determination
go ahead oh sorry i've been meaning to
go to reuters next so we'll go for it to
you next go ahead thank you so much
so you mentioned that there will be
adjustments to or there could be
adjustments to
asp one component of that
is that was really important as far as
the campaign promise was the 15
minimum wage the president has already
signaled that that may not make it into
the full package
how important is that measure still to
the white house and how you get it done
and then also the other thing that came
up this weekend is looking at
tweaking the level of who gets the
stimulus checks and janet yellen
mentioned sixty thousand can you explain
who gets left out right you know if you
get the 60 if you you know who is
between the sixty thousand and the
seventy five thousand
sure uh well the first question uh the
president is
remains firmly committed to raising the
minimum wage to 15
that's why he put it in his first
legislative proposal and he doesn't
he believes in any american who is
working a full-time job
trying to make ends meet should not be
at the poverty level and it's important
to him uh that
the minimum wage uh is raised um he was
referring this weekend to
as you noted in your question uh the
parliamentary process obviously it's
the most likely path at this point is
through a reconciliation process
uh there is a parliamentarian who will
make uh decisions about what can end up
in a final package
and that was certainly what he was
referencing uh in his comments
uh in terms of what the options are uh
we'll see what the parliamentarian
decides and then uh
we'll see what additional options are
but we're getting a little ahead of
where we are at this point in the
process i'm sure we can continue to have
a discussion about it in here
uh and then say your second question one
more time
sure well one of the pieces that the
president has talked about
is uh his openness to engaging and
having a discussion about
what is called kind of the unofficially
called i guess the scale
up right so uh his proposal as you know
uh had proposed uh fourteen hundred
dollar checks to make the two thousand
dollars
uh whole uh he had proposed kind of a
threshold there's a discussion right now
about what that threshold will look like
a conclusion hasn't
uh been finalized that will be worked
through congress but
either way his bottom line is that
families making 275
300 000 a year may not be the most in
need
of checks at this point in time but
whatever the threshold is there will be
a scale up
so uh his view is that a nurse a teacher
a firefighter who's making
sixty thousand dollars shouldn't be left
without any support or relief
either uh it's just a question of sort
of where the scale up looks like what it
looks like in a final package but it's
still being negotiated at this point in
time
yeah the 15 you know it it doesn't
make it much harder to get it through if
you don't attach it to this covered with
bill i mean does that really and then
the cbo is saying that
in fact if you did go through with it
that you
you know it would lead to a 0.9
reduction in the number of
jobs well i i i heard about the cbo
score as i was
walking out here so i haven't talked
with our economic team
about that specifically um and at this
point in time it's still working its way
through the process in congress and the
parliamentarian still has to make a
determination about what will be in a
final package
uh oh i promise to go to you first next
i should say go ahead
i have a couple questions on cobra but i
don't like to start with iran
sure um president biden said that the us
would not
lift sanctions first and that iran would
have to stop enriching
uranium before negotiations could resume
but since then
the supreme leader has said that the us
has to act first and roll back sanctions
in order to re-engage
is this a non-negotiable point for
president biden and if so how do you
get out of this stalemate well just to
be very clear
the president never said that exactly it
was stated by the interviewer who
norah o'donnell who did the interview
interview and he didn't
respond to the question so the
president's view position
is that if iran comes back into full
i think if we were announcing a major
policy change we would do it in a
different way than a slight head nod but
uh overall his position has remains
exactly what
it has been which is that if iran comes
into full compliance with its
obligations under the jcpoa
uh the united states would do the same
and then use that as a platform to build
a larger and stronger agreement that
also addresses other areas of concern
and that would of course be done with
our p5 plus one partners as it was done
uh when we were putting together the
jcpoa in the first place
so what's the response to iran's
argument that it was actually the u.s
that violated the jcpoa by abandoning it
and therefore it's the us's burden to
reengage well that those were actions of
the former administration as you know uh
and president biden of course was a part
of an administration that
we're advocating for the plan to be put
together uh to begin with but
uh i think his position the position of
our national security team and
the position uh that he's been in
discussion with our partners about or
should say conveying to our partners is
that
it's really up to iran to be come back
into full compliance and
uh with its obligations under the jcpoa
and
uh at that point uh we could move the
discussion forward
can you talk about the concrete steps
the administration is doing
to target and stop the spread of the
variance we keep hearing about
does that include surging vaccines to
areas impacted like south florida
or california with the b117 string
well i know for those of you and i know
we had a lot of briefings today uh who
had the opportunity to uh
participate in the briefing with some of
our medical and health experts they
talked about the importance of
not only vaccination
getting the vaccine when you're eligible
uh that that is a
protective step obviously and also
abiding by a number of the mitigation
steps that
uh our health experts have recommended
uh
but beyond that i i don't i'm not going
to go beyond the advice of our health
and medical experts at this point in
time
uh go ahead caitlin two questions for
you one on the minimum wage you're
saying it's up to the parliamentarian to
make a decision about whether that can
be included
in here of course we know senator
sanders said they're still waiting on
that but
technically the vice president could
overrule the parliamentarian on this and
it hasn't happened in a long time but
is that an option the white house is
considering would vice pres or would
president biden want vice president
harris
to overrule the parliamentarian to
include this
in this package well i'm not aware of
that being allowed
i'd certainly take you at your word i
think our view is that
the parliamentarian is who is chosen
typically
uh to make a decision in a nonpartisan
manner
in terms of what can be included in a
package that goes through reconciliation
is the proper process to for this uh to
journey through
so when president biden told cbs that he
did not think it was going to survive
what was who had told him that he it
wasn't going to make it through likely
well as the president was in uh
congress for in the senate for 36 years
again it still has not worked its way
through
the process and that can take a bit of
time and we certainly defer to the
parliamentarian and
members of the house and of the senate i
should say to give you a better
assessment of what the timeline looks
like okay i have another question
but just to be clear so if the
parliamentarian says no
no 15 minimum wage that's the decision
the white house is going
well let's wait and see what they say
and the president remains committed to
raising the minimum wage it's something
he talked about on the campaign trail
something he firmly believes in
as a as a person and as a leader but
there hasn't been a determination made
at this point in time okay impeachment
the president and the white house has
not said either way if he believes that
former president trump should be
convicted
by the senate in this trial but if he
doesn't believe that he should get
access to intelligence briefings why
can't he say whether or not
he should be convicted by the senate
he's no longer in the senate
he's retired from the senate and he's
president of the united states and his
focus is on
getting relief to the american people
and that's exactly what he's conveyed
publicly of course and privately as well
and he'll leave it to
his former colleagues in the senate or
members of the senate to determine the
path forward
but doesn't he think that someone if he
believes his behavior is too erratic to
get access to intelligence then doesn't
he believe that he should be barred from
holding office again
well he ran against him because he felt
he was unfit for office and he
defeated him and that's why he's no
longer
president trump is no longer president
of the united states so i think his
views of the former president
are pretty clear uh but he's going to
leave at the senate to see this
impeachment proceedings forward through
all the evidence is heard in the
impeachment trial and then secondly a
question on myanmar
uh what is the us doing to perhaps
accelerate some of the action we're
seeing over the weekend with
with protests and secondly how concerned
is the u.s about china
which has not stepped in forcefully and
is not calling it a coup
sure um uh we have been our national
security team has been in touch with the
number of our partners and allies we've
obviously
we were outspoken quite quickly um in
the days following the coup uh and we
named it
designated it a coup very quickly uh in
terms of what actions we're taking there
are considerations that are
underway or policy processes that are
underway on our national security team
as we speak i don't have an update on
that today but
when we do we'll certainly make you all
abreast of that and certainly we are
concerned about
china's absence from the conversation
and lack of a vocal uh
role here on the first question
the president was asked about this this
morning and he made pretty clear he
wasn't
planning to speak to it so i again he's
no longer in the senate and
we put out a statement at the conclusion
of the
house proceedings i
certainly would consider doing that at
the conclusion of the senate but i don't
expect that he's going to
uh be you know posturing or commenting
on this through the course of the
week go ahead thank you jen i do have a
question
but first on energy when is it that the
administration is going to
let the thousands of uh fossil fuel
industry workers whether it's pipeline
workers or construction workers
who are either out of work or will soon
be out of work because of a vitamin eo
when it is and where it is that they can
go for their green job
and that is something the administration
has promised there is now
a gap so i'm just curious when that
happens when those people can count on
that
well i'd certainly welcome you to
present your data of all the thousands
and thousands of people who
uh won't be getting a green job maybe
next time you're here you can present
that but you said that they would be
getting green jobs so i'm just asking
when that happened
uh richard trumka who is a friend
long-time friend of joe biden says
about that day one keystone eo he says i
wish
he the president had paired that more
carefully with the thing that he did
second by saying
here's where we are creating the jobs so
there's partial evidence from richard
trunka well
you didn't include all of his interviews
would you like to include the rest
so how about this uh the laborers
international union of north america
said the keystone decision will cost
1 000 existing union jobs and ten
thousand projected construction jobs
well what mr trump also indicated
in the same interview was that president
biden has proposed a climate plan with
transformative investments in
infrastructure
and laid out a plan that will not only
create millions of good union jobs but
also help
tackle the climate crisis and as the
president has indicated when he gave his
prime time address
uh to talk about the american rescue
plan he talked about his plans to
also put forward a jobs plan uh in the
in the weeks or months following and he
has every plan to do exactly that
but there are people living paycheck to
paycheck there are now people out of job
once the keystone pipe out of jobs once
the keystone pipeline
stopped construction spent 12 days since
gina mccarthy and john kerry were here
and it's been 19 days since that year so
what are these people who need money now
when do they get their green job well uh
the the president and many democrats and
republicans in congress
believe that investment in
infrastructure building infrastructure
that's international interests and
boosts the us economy creates
good paying union jobs here in america
and advances our climate and clean
energy goals are something that
we can certainly work on doing together
and he has every plan to
uh share more about his uh details of
that plan in the weeks ahead
just a quick one on the stimulus there's
reporting that house democrats are going
to come out with a 3 000
per child stimulus for some eligible
families
is that something that the white house
supports making a permanent
benefit well the president talked about
this
a bit on the campaign trail and the
importance of
child tax credits to help working
families
ensure they can make it ends meet this
proposal is
emergency funding as i understand it uh
it's a central priority
of his first legislative proposal to cut
child poverty ha
in half in in the first this year sorry
um
and that's why he included a child tax
credit in the american rescue plan uh
but that's again emergency funding and
something that will help people get
through this period of time
okay go ahead follow up peter's question
sure what's this white house's stance on
a universal basic
income this idea of the government
giving out regular checks on a routine
basis to americans who
might need it i know that's been
proposed by a number of people including
some on the presidential campaign trail
i don't have anything more for you on it
i'm happy to check with our economic
team if that's uh something that they're
looking at at all
do you agree with the need that that
many on the hill and not just democrats
are expressing that there ought to be
these enormous well i won't say enormous
but 3 000 or 4 000
per child checks for families right now
as i tried to just indicate i mean the
president supports uh the proposal
uh that uh representative neil and
others have put forward to
uh ensure that there is um
uh money in the in the package that
helps
bring relief to families in the form of
a child tax credit something he
certainly would support
go ahead thanks and i have two questions
one of the other things that secretary
yellen said yesterday
is that the president is open to a
mandate
on family leave and child care is there
a timetable
on that i don't have any more
details or a timetable for you
certainly as a father himself this is an
issue that he has spoken about in the
past
um but i don't have any more details at
this point in time
yesterday did the president or did the
white house have any concern
about what we all saw on a tv from tampa
about the thousands of people out
celebrating and without masks
any concern there certainly i mean the
president
i haven't spoken with him specifically
about the events of this weekend
but you know he did a psa yesterday with
dr biden making clear that
social distancing that mask wearing that
getting the vaccine when you have
the opportunity to get the vaccine are
vital steps to keeping
uh more americans safe and saving more
lives
uh and certainly uh we know the super
bowl looked not
like different from what it has in the
past and he
also conveyed that he's hopeful that
next year will be a moment where
everybody can celebrate
and party but he is of course concerned
when there are
pictures and photos we all are that show
many many people without masks
um in close distance with one another at
the height of a pandemic
go ahead um i have two questions
first um president biden said
in in the cbs interview that um he
hadn't spoken president xi yet because
he had to have an occasion to talk to
him
there's no reason not to call him but
has there been
is it is it actually part of the
strategy to not call him yet and to hold
off on that
in hopes of kind of sending a message to
china that
that that you know president biden is
not going to
you know try to work
you know really hard to curry favor is
there something happening there i know
well part of our strategy is to um
consult closely with our partners and
allies and you saw we
did readouts of these calls over the
past week or so that he spoke
the president spoke with the prime
minister of japan he spoke with the
prime minister of south korea
he spoke with the prime minister of
australia and um
china was of course an important topic
of conversation
during those conversations he also
discussed china with
uh in calls with his european allies
thus far so
part of our strategy is certainly
engaging with partners in the region
and allies and doing those calls and
engagements first and also having
consultations with
democrats and republicans on capitol
hill uh we've only
i know i can't say this forever but
we've only been here two and a half
weeks um he has not called every global
leader
uh yet he's not had engagements with all
of them and uh
i'm sure he will uh do more of that in
the weeks ahead
who is somebody who is not quite an ally
um certainly not so so
um and that was more than a week ago at
this point yes but he
but he had that conversation in part
because there was a timeline for a new
start and the deadline that was
approaching with new start and
during that conversation he made very
clear that there
are uh significant concerns he has the
administration has about
uh the reported actions of the russian
government
uh but for the most part his other calls
have been with partners and allies in
the region and in asia and in europe as
well at this point in time
and then on something else uh ron clean
said on january 21st that the
administration was going to try to build
what he described as a national clearing
house for information about the coven
vaccine
um is something like that being built um
in the administration
and if so how long do you think that's
going to take i think people
are really struggling to find
information about their state their
county
um and you know there's just so there's
so much difficulty in the vaccination
process
you're right there's a great deal of
confusion um and
one of the uh focuses we have had is
trying to
um alleviate that confusion and part of
that
has been through working with governors
and local elected officials one of their
biggest requests has been to have more
of a
heads up on how much vaccine supply
there would be of course to increase
vaccine supply we've worked to do both
to give
ensure that there is through planning
time for vaccine allocation
increases in allotments to supply allows
and of course deploying government
resources to sites where they are needed
we're looking at a host of measures that
could help us achieve
our goal of course of getting 100
million vaccines in the arms of
americans in the first hundred days and
also ensuring that we're reaching
uh communities where there are higher
levels of vaccine
hesitancy um but uh the president and
the president has directed his team to
use whatever tools and resources
necessary to get the job done
so the range of options under
consideration but i don't have any
updates for you on that particular
uh proposal uh certainly a lot of people
would love that but we're looking to
prioritize
how we can be most impactful as quickly
as possible and working with
states and governors to make those
determinations
uh go ahead again uh thank you back on
impeachment
sure you mentioned that uh the president
will be in close contact
uh with senator schumer do you expect
that to be daily
uh have they for example have they
spoken since
he's gotten back uh from delaware do you
like will that be a regular way
that the president is briefed on on the
progress
of the impeachment trial i don't expect
that would be a primary topic i
actually expect it would be more about
the american rescue plan
and progress being made on that front
there of course
markups happening this week more on the
house side uh
and the president has remained in close
touch with
speaker pelosi and leader schumer very
regularly
over the course of the last few weeks
and i expect that would continue
they will have any strategy discussions
at all
as the trial is unfolding i don't expect
that would be a primary
point of discussion of their
conversations
he's busy and he's not going to be
spending moment by moment uh
attention to it this week but i will he
get a daily
update for perhaps more frequently
than that from white house staff i
i don't expect that will be a primary
focus for him this week or of
his senior staff either another
important policy question
drawing on the question about iran
uh when the president ruled out uh
dropping u.s
sections uh immediately uh he
didn't then go on and talk about some of
the other strategies that are that are
out there
including for example that the united
states might drop its objections
to iran receiving an imf loan
uh credit related imf loan other couple
other ideas
that would allow iran to get some
uh economic benefit that that would not
be sanctions
and maybe grease the wheel for
negotiations does the president have a
view on
that on those strategies and were they
part of the discussion
uh at the uh principles meeting on
friday
i i'm not gonna rule i read out a
principles meeting which was
primarily focused on a range of issues
in the middle east of course iran was a
topic of discussion
uh our voice was expected to be a topic
of discussion
i think during the interview the
president was asked about uh
whether he would uh roll back sanctions
and he conveyed
no that it's the wall is in iran's court
it wasn't a more extensive conversation
than that
during the interview um and that's long
been his position
so that really is the next step in terms
of engagement
um with iran from
ruling it here necessarily that that
there might be other ways
to to uh help iran get back to the table
that would be short of dropping
u.s sanctions uh well again i think
his view is that the ball is in iran's
court
to uh come back into full compliance
with the jcpoa
and that that would be uh the basis for
uh the united states doing the same and
then using that as a platform to build a
longer and stronger agreement
but that is really the next step in his
view in the process
if i could um on time uh first class
mail delivery
dropped to 38 in uh december of this
year from 92 percent the year before
does the president have a view on
whether the postmaster general should
keep his job
and uh if he would like to see the
postmaster general removed
would he move to change the makeup of
the governing board that could make that
happen
well as i understand it there are a
number of openings right now on the
governing board of the post office
or vacancies i should say that would of
course work their way through a
personnel process
i don't think i have anything more for
it on this for you but
i can follow up with our team and see
what more we can report out
go ahead um back on the subject of the
covid checks
bernie sanders said it would be absurd
to lower the threshold
the income threshold and some other
democrats have raised
the prospect that doing so could lead to
a political backlash
given voters in georgia were explicitly
promised this aid
by the president and they didn't really
have any reason to believe that
fewer people would qualify for that aid
under the democrats
plan so i'm wondering if that's
something you guys are concerned about
and how you would address that criticism
well
uh the president proposed uh the 1400
checks to make to to cut plus 600 is of
course 2 000
because he was felt it was important and
vital to get that direct relief to
as many americans as possible and target
that relief to the americans who need
help the most and that's how his
original plan and proposal was designed
he's also said and i've said many times
from here that
the final plan will look different from
what the plan he proposed in his joint
session address it's still working its
way
through congress and i don't think a
conclusion has been
uh made yet on the exact level of
targeting and when it does we're happy
to have a conversation about that but
part of this is is uh you know an
opportunity for
members of both parties and members who
are across the political spectrum of
course even in the democratic party to
weigh in on what the path forward should
look like go ahead in the back
thank you jen a little bit of follow-up
on a iran and china question
uh what does president biden consider uh
the biggest threat to the u.s national
security
overall in the world yes well i i'm not
sure i'm going to define that for you in
this moment there are a range of threats
that he's talked about uh in the past um
and
i'm sure he'll have more to say on his
national security approach and strategy
in the in the weeks ahead
one question last week a report made by
ngos
and universities was sent to the white
house recommending that united
states break negotiations on trade
and others with brazil over climate and
human rights violation
and likewise some democrats on the hill
already had expressed the same
opposition to expand economic economic
partnership with brazil is the white
house paying attention
to those reports and to what's happening
in brazil
oh we certainly are paying close
attention to
what is happening in brazil obviously
we share a vibrant partnership that
spans two centuries of mutual interest
and shared values
and we you know have even announced in
recent
days uh you know on february 5th the
united states government through the us
through usaid announced it has delivered
an additional 1.5 million dollars in
emergency coveted response in brazil
um and we of course uh remain
um you know closely engaged in these in
what is a significant economic
uh relationship um uh we are by far the
largest investor in brazil including in
many of brazil's most innovative and
growth focused
companies and we'll continue to
strengthen our economic ties
and increase our large and growing trade
relationship in the months ahead
but in the policies of the brazilian
president and president biden
on the many issues climate um
gay rights uh other other ones are very
different
how can they work together well just as
is true in many of our relationships we
look for
opportunities to work together on issues
where there is
joint national interest uh and obviously
there's an
a significant economic relationship and
we will
uh not hold back on areas where we
disagree whether it's climate or human
rights uh or
uh or otherwise and so that will be uh
the path forward with our relationship
with brazil as well
go ahead yamiche thanks so much the
first is
what should americans take away from the
fact that president biden
campaigned on unity talked about unity
got into office
about two weeks in has decided all but
it's decided it seems
to go with a process where democrats can
pass
a 1.9 trillion dollar plan without the
support of republicans i know
that there are republicans across the
country that the white house is pointing
to saying
they support this bill um but there is
this
there is the fact that democrats don't
have to have
republican support in congress for this
bill and the president
is seemingly supporting that process i'm
wondering what people should take away
from that and
will that definition of bipartisanship
be the one that
that's going forward with this white
house well the
president ran on unifying the country
not on creating one political party
but i will note that uh 16 of the last
21 reconciliation bills that have gone
through congress have been bipartisan
and certainly there's opportunity for
republicans to not only offer amendments
as it's going through the house
committee process and then we'll go
through the senate committee process
following that
but they will have the opportunity to of
course vote for a package that will
that the vast majority of the american
people
support uh so uh you know the president
is
is his first priority is getting relief
to the american people
but the vast majority of the public
democrats republicans independents are
with him in that effort
there's a long history of bipartisan
support for reconciliation bills a
parliamentary process again i don't
think the american people are
particularly worried about
how the direct relief gets to their into
their hands uh
and you know that if that's the process
that uh
it moves forward through which seems
likely at this point the president would
certainly support that
i have a question also on um impeachment
i know
the president you say isn't going to be
watching it but there are going to be
millions of americans
who will be watching it i wonder what
the president's message is the americans
especially the ones that are still
warning the loss
of people who died in the capitol who
are still wondering whether or not
the president and former president trump
will be possibly
acquitted in the in this trial even if
he even if biden doesn't want
president fighting doesn't want to say
whether or not president trump should be
convicted i just wonder if the white
house has any message to americans who
are gearing up for could what could be a
tumultuous
and traumatic two weeks well the
president's
focus is on delivering what those
millions and millions and millions of
americans care deeply about which is
getting the pandemic under control
putting 10 million
amer you know putting millions of
americans back to work getting vaccines
in the arms of americans
reopening schools and he has been clear
that he views the events of january 6 as
a horrific
attack on our democracy he put out a
statement we put out a statement from
him i should say
when the house voted but he's going to
leave it to the senate
to determine the path forward here uh
that doesn't change
uh you know and in his view is that he
was elected to uh
deliver on uh the promises he made on
the campaign trail so that's what he's
going to keep his focus on
in the weeks ahead go ahead oh go ahead
james
saying that the gop can offer amendments
um that doesn't mean that they have to
listen to them or accept them so i
wonder then if republicans
um have to just accept what the
democrats have approved i just wonder if
you could talk a bit more about this
definition of bipartisanship because
there is this
i know you're saying the democrats and
are giving republicans the opportunity
but there's still this
this idea that democrats are in two
weeks in are going it alone
well again uh 16 of 21 reconciliation
bills in the past have received
bipartisan support
and the ideas in this package the
proposals in this package
have broad support from democrats
republicans and independents
um across the country so i would pose
the question back to
republicans why aren't you supporting
what the vast majority of the public
supports um i'll leave it at that go
ahead
completely different topic which is
defense secretary lloyd austin wrote
his first memo on january 23 um that the
president had ordered a 90-day
commission to pursue solutions
to sexual assault in the military i'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about if that's a white house commission
a defense commission who picks the
commissioners anything more you can say
about that commission that's supposed to
be looking
at sexual assault in the military i
believe it's a commission
at the department of defense it's
certainly an initiative the president of
the united states supports but i would
send you to the department of defense
for more specifics about the timeline
and membership
go ahead with the some of the crises
that the nation has faced in recent
months you've got
more than 400 000 americans dead january
6th
the attack on american democracy there
have been calls for a 911 style
commission to write the official
histories of those events with is that
something the president would support
of the covid commission or 9 11. i'm
sorry or january 6th
uh well you know a determination of that
kind would be made by congress
as you well know um and his focus at
this point in time is on
uh addressing the crisis in this moment
right which is
uh ensuring that more americans get
shots in their arms that we are getting
the pandemic under control
uh there has been a report by hhs
looking
at the prior administration's handling
of the covid
uh crisis and we've also not held back
in areas where we felt that
um it was handled in a way that um
impacted the lives of millions uh
so uh but at this point in time our
focus is really on getting the pandemic
under control and
we'll leave that decision up to congress
go ahead
two quick ones uh one news of the day
has president biden reached out to
anybody from the tampa bay buccaneers
and
if not is that something that's gonna
happen today it's very exciting
uh the outcome of the super bowl i guess
if you're a fan of the buccaneers but um
we will be inviting i don't have an
update for if it's happened yet but i do
have an update that that
we look forward to inviting the
buccaneers as well as the 2020
nba champions the lakers to the white
house when it is coveted safe
but i don't know when that will take
place yet thank you and on immigration
there's a new reporting that ice
uh is going to get some new guidance to
no longer
focus on deporting illegal immigrants
who have been convicted of dui
simple assault solicitation drug-based
crimes among other things
and i'm curious how that is in the
interest of public safety
well uh first it's guidelines that would
be uh put out by the department of
homeland security and i'd certainly send
you them they have a confirmed secretary
now uh but uh the priority for the
enforcement
of an immigration laws uh will be on
those who are posing a national security
threat of course a public safety threat
and on recent
arrivals nobody is saying that duis or
assault are acceptable
behavior and those arrested for such
activity should be tried and sentenced
as appropriate by local law enforcement
but we're talking about the
prioritization of who is going to be
deported from the country and more
broadly would this be what
biden was talking about in the debate
where he said in the obama
administration
uh they didn't do enough to reform the
immigration system
because he was just vice president but
that if he was president things would
change is this the kind of change that
he was talking about
well i think the kind of change he was
talking about was
uh putting forward an immigration bill
at a time where
modernization of immigration is long
overdue that
addresses not only a pathway to
citizenship but puts in place smart
security measures and addresses the root
causes
of these issues in the countries uh in
central america
so i think that's primarily what he was
referring to but also prioritization
which again
would be up to the department of
homeland security uh to ensure our focus
is on
the individuals who pose the greatest
national security threat is also
something he's long supported
uh go ahead kayla sorry uh you seem to
be seeing this but i try
it to be yeah president former president
trump has not requested any intelligence
briefings right
not not that i'm aware of but you i
would point you to the uh
intelligence community and the odni for
more specifics
why is there a reason morgan muir is no
longer leading president biden's daily
intelligence briefings
i believe he's overseeing uh the process
of preparing materials uh but i don't
have any more details i'd point you to
od and eye on that as well okay so
there's no reason you know that he's not
leading the in-person briefings he's
assembling the daily break yeah
leading them in person which is a very
important role to play and very
uh very labor-intensive uh but i would
point you to them for more specifics on
the briefings and who will be providing
the briefings good thanks jen i have two
questions one it's a quick follow-on
enchantment aside from the particulars
of this case
does president biden think it's
constitutional
to impeach and convict a former
president who is no longer in office
i'm just not going to have any more for
you on weighing in on impeachment i
appreciate the
it's a big story um but our focus is on
the american rescue plan and
uh delivering for the american people
coveted crisis related questions um
because the attacks in the asian
american community
continue to rise and over the weekend
there are some videos that went viral
because
elderly asian americans were really
attacked and um in a
way that is difficult to watch and i
wonder other than the presidential
memorandum
is president biden going to take any
further actions
to address this problem um
or and has he seen the videos i'm not
aware that he's seen the videos but he
is concerned
about the discrimination against
the actions against the asian american
community which is why he signed
the executive order and why he has been
outspoken and
making clear that um you know attacks
verbal attacks any attacks of any form
are unacceptable and we need to work
together
uh to address them uh but obviously the
executive order is something he did
very early in his administration still
early but even earlier um because he
felt it was so important to put a marker
down
is there anything more that can be done
like offer doj or fbi assistance
to local law enforcement authorities i
mean i
i'd certainly defer to you know we would
support of course uh
additional action on a local level a
federal level but i would send you to
doj or fbi for any further specifics on
that
thank you everyone see you tomorrow
you